now gathers and now my watch begins
it shall not end until my death I shall
take no wife I shall wear no crowns and
win no glory I shall live and die at my
post I am the sword in the darkness I am
the Watcher on the walls I pledge my
life and honor to the Nights Watch for
this night and all the nights to come
the Nights Watch are sworn Brotherhood
that defend the wall the wall is a
gigantic wall of ice it's a hundred
leagues long from coast to coast it goes
across the entire width of Westeros
which is rather narrow at that point and
its highest 700 feet high and it's
located hundreds of miles north of
it's the boundary of the kingdom of the
north beyond that is the wild is the one
that forest is lands where no one the
wall was built thousands and thousands
of years ago for reasons that have been
lost in the mists of time but legend as
it was built to keep the things in the
North out there are many dangers that
lurk beyond the wall beasts the
wildlings which are essentially northern
barbarians but the most fearsome are the
White Walkers no one has seen them for
thousands of years has gone to the point
where some people believe they never
existed or simply creatures out of
mythology you came alone without friends
nor honor you came to us rich you came
to us poor some of you bear the names of
proud houses others only bastard names
or no names that's all it does not
matter all that is in the past the
Nights Watch is an order of man
dedicated to protecting the wall and
protecting the Seven Kingdoms from all
the dangers that lurk beyond next time I
see you the building black it was always
my color there also called the black
brothers they dress in all black and
they live a very hard life they're kind
of a cross between an ancient monastic
order and the Special Forces Brigade
when you're doing the Nights Watch when
you take the black as it's cold you're
joining for life it's not the sentence
of a few years take that oath you say
those words and you'll spend the rest of
your life on the wall to understand why
you'd be giving up we have no families
none of us will ever father some I don't
care about that the past is irrelevant
your commitment to the wall is absolute
it is for the rest of your life and you
will forego such common niceties as
having a home and the family those
things are gone give my regards to Madge
watch I'm sure it will be thrilling to
serve in such an elite force and if not
it's only for life you've got to really
really believe in it
or you've got to feel that you've got
nothing left to lose
they've sworn themselves to lifelong
service so if you desert your executed
you want to run away South run away of
course they will behead you as a
deserter their loyalty is to the realm
as a whole not to any particular house
or Kingdom which makes them very
different from all the other people we
encounter in the Seven Kingdoms who tend
to be more loyal to their particular
families and houses than they are to
this concept of the greater realm lovely
thing about the watch discard your old
family and get a whole new one not
everybody wants to be there but
everybody's put together and strength
people who were strangers yesterday you
have to get used to being very very very
close to the people who have got a lot
of time unsavory people no loyalty no
sense of duty people of all sorts of
problematic backgrounds come together
and essentially walk what it becomes is
a brotherhood it doesn't matter where
you're from doesn't matter who you are
once you're accepted and you pass all
the training that they do then you
become part of that Brotherhood and
everything before is washed away and you
start anew as this new person here on
the wall we are all one house the watch
is
commanded by a Lord Commander who serves
for life but is elected by the sworn
brothers within the Nights Watch there
three waters the stewards who
essentially take care of all the
housekeeping you know the upkeep there's
the order of the builders who have
charged with maintaining the wall
maintaining the castles and there are
the Rangers who are probably the
fighting core of the Nights Watch and
Ben and Stark is the first Ranger of the
watch the first Ranger's role is to ride
out beyond the wall keep the wall thing
out from the rest of the civilized world
basically I'm leaving this morning
you're leaving I'm the first Ranger the
job is out there the Nights Watch
was at one time a place that was a very
respectable place for second third sons
of respectable families to send their
children when you are the third son you
know that you are not going to be the
Lord of castle and you know that you're
not going to inherit your father's lands
and Nights Watch is a place where you
could go to distinguish yourself and
it's there's still remnants of that a
Boston boy nothing to inherit off to
join the Ancient Order of the Nights
Watch if you join the Nights Watch
it's a merit-based Society which mostly
which don't exist in Westeros so at the
wall if you're brave enough if you were
smart enough if you're
in advance to high position despite
where you were born we were born - and
so forth well Lord snow it appears
you're the least useless person here a
charming man
they'll need him to be charming I need
to turn this bunch of thieves and
Runaways into men of the Nights Watch
and how's that going
life in the Nights Watch is hard because
the Nights Watch is is fallen on hard
times Night's Watch has become an army
of undisciplined boys and tired old men
less than a thousand of us now
we can't properly patrol the wilderness
the threats beyond the wall seem less
and less because there's been longer in
Augustine's anything's it played any
threat to the kingdoms from the war so
less and less people are sent up there
to protect Night's Watch protects the
rious yes against grumpkins and snarks
and all the other monsters your wet
nurse warned you about get a smart boy
you don't believe that nonsense when the
memory of the things that lie beyond the
wall when the memory was fresh in
people's mind and i swatched was very
honorable and very well respected it's
now primarily a kind of a repository for
thieves and rapists and ne'er-do-wells
who are dragged out of dungeons and
given like a choice between losing their
hands or going up to the wall rapist
they were given a choice no doubt
castration or the world most choose the
knife it's it's fallen on hard times
your sister six for the side of the king
teller we need help it's a hard place to
live and it's a cold place to live
one of the wall is equal and you won't
get anywhere unless you accept that fact
first it's ultimately the kind of a
place that can very easily
I think break people or it can make them
stronger what are the only thing
standing between the realm and what lies
beyond and winter does come God's help
us all if we're not ready